the honeydew with y'all
thank you for your support here's ryan
sickler
welcome back to the honeydew with y'all
y'all we're over here doing it in the
night pants studios i'm ryan sickler
thank you all for your support you're
the die hards i love you
uh you all know what we're doing over
here just a heads up make sure your
credit cards are current um and if you
want to save a few bucks you know sign
up for that yearly subscription and save
yourself some money you'll get over a
month of free episodes all right look in
the end credits also for your name we're
updating them almost every episode
you'll see your name up there and thank
you for your support this week got a
guest here who sent me an email that was
i mean literally eye-catching uh we're
gonna get into that story here in a
minute but let me introduce ladies and
gentlemen this is damn batiste y'all
welcome to the honeydew of the all day
amputees
can we you here what up dude there you
are first guest down here i think you're
the first guest to smoke is that a
cigarette that's what ash said i think
you are he is right ash
yeah you're the first guest to smoke i
don't remember if we had a vapor but
you're definitely the first guest to
smoke i believe well i'm a dirt bag dude
well
dirtbags are welcome here all honeydew
is my friend and uh it is nice to meet
you where where are you right now in the
world i am in rutland vermont baby
rutland vermont we were talking small
town in the middle of nowhere vermont
near killington which i was familiar
with i've been to your state you have a
beautiful state i've been to your
capital
i've been to the ben jerry's tour got me
some free ice cream
you know did all your maple syrup [ __ ]
you know did all that i've been there
vermont's great
um how old are you dan it's home i am 35
years old you look younger you look good
you look i was gonna say well thank you
28 to 30 dan
uh and what do you do for a living dan
i am a welder and
a general dirt bag do whatever the hell
it is it takes to make money all right
so you look younger but you look exactly
like what you should be doing for a
living yeah
sir
do what it is i gotta [ __ ] all right
so
you sent me an email that uh just
i mean
blew my mind let's say how about that
and uh why don't we start with can we
start with that story first and then
we'll talk about
why you are involved with these types of
people in these types of situations
okay
so
let's let's start it's uh it's philly
it's 2009.
um it is the height of the
heroin epidemic in all of the northeast
and um
we'll call him
jerry because i honestly never actually
knew his [ __ ] name
but um i had been doing heroin for about
three or four years at this point all
right so let me ask you questions along
the way as i like to do so when you say
heroin because i had a lot of friends
who started with the opiates and the
scripts and the scripts run out and then
you start getting the heroine so is that
yep yeah it seems to be a video
i was doing
yep i was doing i was doing 80s
oxycontin 80s and percocet and you know
basically how many of that like how many
a day were you up to
at the height of it yeah the height was
oxycontin i was doing heroin
i don't know
i don't know if i'd describe hair of my
heroine abuse at the height of it i
think it would be the low light
you know what my worst you mean you're
like at my best
well i mean when it was the worst i was
doing um
probably five
oxy 80s a day so that's
four um milligrams is that what that is
an 80 milligram is that what that is
ballpark
ballpark
um
yeah that sounds about right so
i was uh
and now now give me hold on walk me
through a a bad day
five odds how many perks how many i mean
are you at heroin then what what's
happening no no no i didn't start doing
heroin until i moved to philly
so what got you hooked on the pills
originally was there an actual injury
that did or was it recreational
no i was just a sad boy okay
um i you know i came from a great family
i have my parents
i mean granted my both
my parents like they were divorced but i
had great great families like it's not
like oh my parents the whole thing like
no dude i had a great family
and it
was just basically me being [ __ ]
boo hoo like i didn't have anything
going on i was just
i was just basically a douche nozzle at
that point
and how old are you
mid-20s early 20s
uh when i first started i think i was
22 i remember the first
i remember the first day i [ __ ] got
high off pills i was 22
and i did
about [ __ ] three perk 30s
and i [ __ ] you know i snarted them
and
you snorted them yeah
yeah that's how you fur you didn't even
take them orally you just snorted them
holy [ __ ] i remember the first time i
took them
i was in my
30s late 30s i took them for an injury
and cuz you're a [ __ ] i am and it made
me throw up it broke me out and oh dude
the throw up was the best part
no but you didn't get the spins you
didn't get the spoons oh dude the spins
the puking things i'm not that part
that's how you knew your highest [ __ ] i
knew i knew believe me
bro i'm dude i was so about that [ __ ]
like if i didn't throw up i was pissed
off i was like didn't even [ __ ] touch
me
and you don't feel like after you throw
up
no see i wouldn't that's what i'm saying
i wouldn't stop spinning it would just
keep going
oh dude you're one of those i'm allergic
to it my doctor's like you're allergic
that's what she said yeah
come on i'll take it i'm so glad i'm
glad
i'm glad i've watched family yeah i know
i've watched family go through it it was
the grossest like
all right so you you snort these perks
and then are you immediately hooked are
you day every day after that day one day
the first time i got high dude like
people people always say like oh it only
takes one time oh [ __ ] facts bro
[ __ ] facts like i do i was a smoker
for years i didn't even smoke weed at
this point i was like nah i'm not about
that
but the [ __ ] first time i got high on
pills dude
done now how long does it take you to go
from pills to actual
heroin
so i started getting high on pills in
2007.
and i did it because i was a spiteful
little piece of [ __ ]
and my ex-girlfriend now this is
i was this is my my first real
girlfriend her sister was a junkie
like an actual junkie like you know i
mean like i became but like
i started doing it because i knew it
would piss her off and that is the
dumbest [ __ ] [ __ ] i've ever said in
my life and i just said it out loud you
did
just said it out loud you did but that
that's that's why dude i did it because
i knew it would [ __ ] upset her
that's that's definitely a 22 year old
thing to [ __ ] do and say like just
[ __ ]
so [ __ ]
yeah like 2006 2007-ish
i
moved to providence and was living with
my dad at the time it was a couple years
after i grad i graduated in 04 so i was
going with him i know we talked about
the story we teed up which we'll come
back to which was philly so you said you
moved are you were you did you start in
vermont and then go down to providence
is that why okay yes so you have roost
in vermont and now you've moved in with
that in providence
right right so i i live with my dad for
like a year or two and i
like it's not even like i fell in with
the wrong crowd i literally [ __ ] just
met a bunch of kids
and then i was
i was working at [ __ ] shaws do you
guys have shaws out there no
it's a grocery store it's like
price chopper or [ __ ] ralph's or
anything like that
it's a grocery store wait you didn't
have them in [ __ ] baltimore not
ralph's no we had safe way we had one no
no no i mean shaw's yeah you didn't have
shaws and no oh
so shaw's was a [ __ ] well still is a
grocery store here in the northeast and
um
i was working there
i met this girl
she was [ __ ] hot
she was meaner than a wet cat
but her boyfriend
had a good connection on oxy's on 80s
dude [ __ ]
40 50 bucks depending on how much he had
you know
so i started
double dabbling with that and being like
oh you know i'll buy a couple here and
there and that'll last me a few days a
few days turned into i need three
every day
that quick
super fun wow so within a few days you
already needed triple
no no no no not a few days not a few
days oh so i should clarify um within
three months i was going from
one every couple of days to
about three
every
two days
so
you think
forty to sixty dollars each
damn is that are they really that much
they were then dude they're so well they
don't even make them anymore like that
dude now they're called ops like you
can't you can't [ __ ] snort them you
can't shoot them you can't smoke them
they have this weird
substance in them where they turn to
basically jelly if you try to do
anything with them so you can't do that
anymore but back in the day dude in like
2006 2007
2008-ish
ballpark
that's
dude that was dude i'd rip i would do
that over a bag of heroin any day
a hundred percent dude
a hundred percent because you knew
exactly what you were getting you knew
it was going to be consistent and it
wasn't gonna kill you if you didn't do
too many of them obviously
okay so
that quickly progresses obviously in a
few months and and where are you getting
your pills are you buying them from a
dealer are you getting screwed doctors
all
i would be like dude so i i i broke my
ankle one time and i got a i got a nice
script to [ __ ] you know percocet at
one point and that was just like
okay so
percocet were like tic tacs you could
just
you eat six or seven of them at that
point for me anyway and
that was to get up and go to work and i
got to ask you because i had trouble
[ __ ] when i was taking these things
are you sh and i had another friend
whose mom had to have surgery because
she got so addicted it backed her whole
system up and she had to get her stomach
cut open i mean are you having trouble
with that
oh dude i would go i think the longest i
ever went without [ __ ] taking a dump
was
two and a half weeks damn
that's a long [ __ ] dude
bro that's that's some any [ __ ] right i
was about to say unless you're annie
that's something that's way too long i'd
be at the doctor like get this out of me
now my dude my
like i went when i finally [ __ ] you
know unfucked myself my doctor was like
how did you go this long i was like i
don't know my body was just like
okay
yeah no dude that's for sure a thing
like
i remember going weeks without taking a
dump
it's for sure a thing so what's the
craziest thing
you did to get heroin does that lead us
to our story
um
yeah no i'll tell you that story the
craziest thing i ever did so i was in a
band um when i lived in philly
and what was your baby all the gear
the lil b zephyr funk odyssey
it was so [ __ ] wild bees
oh dude just a bunch of white kids
[ __ ] playing funk music dude we
thought dude we thought we were [ __ ]
bro i i dude it
yeah no that was the name of the band um
but uh
craziest thing you did
oh
man
i had all of the gear stored at my house
i pawned off
no and when i say put well when i say
pond i didn't sell it i pawned i know
how palm
yeah yep so i [ __ ] took
probably about
five thousand dollars worth of gear and
pawned it
and
you got five for it
uh no
did you go to [ __ ] bro have you ever
been to a pawn shop yeah well i didn't
know if you meant you gave him 15 and
got five or 100 yeah okay that's right
i got like 1500 dude and i bought a
whole lot of skag and i'll tell you
[ __ ] paying back that [ __ ] loan
was a rough
rough day how long did it take you
uh no i paid it back in one shot um i
did i was i was working in the the navy
yard um because i'm a welder and i was
[ __ ] i was doing cutting i was
cutting up ships i was cutting up old
navy ships so i made about [ __ ] old
navy ships i'm laughing yeah yeah dude
that's that's why i'm just laughing like
i know yeah but old navy's what made me
laugh oh dude so i made about fifteen
thousand dollars in
three weeks
i had to go and unfuck that situation
what you did you got it all back
i got it all back dude i never did them
dirty i got all their equipment back
such a dirtbag mode dude it's such a
dirtbag move so
take us to
this story in philly and then i've got a
bunch of questions i want to ask oh i
have so many answers for you okay so
it was summer 2000
i think it was 2010 it was the last
summer i was there
and i used to
buy my heroine either on argyle street
or eighth street which is [ __ ]
hilarious 8th street you bought heroin
on 8th street
i'm not joking dude you look it up bro i
dude so once again you get your crack on
c street
oh dude no i was never about crack i
never got i never got the crack thing i
don't know why people were so about
crack i never got it but um
so it was h street or argyle street one
street was dominicans the other one was
puerto ricans if the dominicans didn't
have anything you [ __ ] walked your
ass over to h street and got it from the
puerto ricans
now
h street was now why did you go
dominicans first was there stuff
generally better than the puerto rican
stuff oh no no no dude it was just the
[ __ ] street closest to where i would
park i see proximity we're talking you
know like he's in the window back there
who's in the window behind you right now
dude
oh
oh my god what are you doing no dude
oh my god you just scared the snot out
of me no it's my friend sam um
hold on i thought we were about to
witness a murder or something on here we
were gonna keep your camera rolling
forward scared the [ __ ] out of me
she was creeping i saw her go by a
couple times dude he literally just said
you were creeping he literally just said
you were creeping hold on i gotta dude i
gotta pay her
did y'all have paypal and [ __ ] so none
of this would be necessary well poke
your face in and say hello at least
dude show your face come on over here
you gotta at least say hi
[Laughter]
now i gotta
okay sorry about that oh there you go
that's
dude you [ __ ] she went by the window
twice i felt like and then all of a
sudden she stuck her face in and i was
like who is this
well there you go no that's so we were
my best friend oh all right we were over
on eighth street uh and it was proximity
was why you went to the dominicans first
because it was the closest street you
parked to argo argyle was the first
street and then eighth street like if
they didn't have anything like if they
were shut down on argyle because you
know that would happen
oh my god dude i'm still laughing about
that um
if argyle was shut down you'd walk over
to h street and there was a bodega
and you would stand out front and
the the homie would come out and he'd
just be like
do you need you know
you get you get what you wanted was
there a certain time but did you have to
ask for like um
lilac roses or was there a code or
anything nope it was that it was that
relax man that is against all codes
dude the drug market is is bad as
baltimore it's open air you go there you
say i need five i need ten you know i
need a bun like you know it depends on
how much money you have i need five
that means you need five bags
and that's [ __ ] you know depending on
who and what and where and you're not
scared to get something spiked something
laced i mean now with the [ __ ]
fentanyl what
no jesus no no
jeff
well
not at that time right i'm saying the
game is already different from what
we're talking about right now yeah no so
it's very different now um i got out
right before the fentanyl thing i was
very lucky i got out in 2016
and i am very very very lucky because
it's a completely different game
like i wouldn't i dude i wouldn't go buy
drugs on the street if you [ __ ] gave
me all the money to go buy all the drugs
forever like i wouldn't do it because
nah dude
it's not it's not like it was in 2010.
like it's not like it was it's
completely different
it's so different
you keep hitting your mic
oh sorry dude i apologize all right
so philly yeah no it's so different dude
it's so different it's not like it was
in 2010 it's completely different
so take us to this philly story
all right so there was this guy
we'll call him jimmy jerry whatever the
[ __ ] you want to call him said jerry
yeah jerry
um he
was that guy who would stand on the
corner one street down and just
literally just stand there and be like
hey man
hey man um can you just help me out can
you help me out like
i just i just need a couple units like i
just need a couple like i don't know if
well you wouldn't know but like um on
needles there's units
so
a couple units would be like you know
two or three little [ __ ]
pops of [ __ ]
[Music]
goodness i guess you would say i don't
know how to put it
um
but he would sit there and he would beg
he would beg people dude never had money
he would just sit there and rub his
hands and just be like please help me
please help me i'm so sick i got to go
to work i'm so sick i'm so sick
dude i could have
i could have 400 worth of dope in my
pocket and i would just say sorry man i
only got enough for myself you know like
i don't i don't know you
like you're weird like please please
don't talk to me type of thing
so
that day
i remember
i parked my car well not my car my
girlfriend's car
but um
i
walked up and
like clockwork please please please like
give me a little bit of this like give
me a couple units like i just need to
get well blah blah blah blah
i was like dude i don't even like i just
got here like i don't even have anything
you know i i've thrown a dude i throw
them bags a few times like because even
i like dude even as a fiend like i'm
still a human i don't want to see
somebody [ __ ] sick dude it [ __ ]
broke my heart but like
that day dude i just i didn't have
enough dude i didn't have enough money i
think i bought [ __ ]
25 bags that was gonna last me the next
two days
like
i walked up
got my [ __ ] and okay so the guy that i
used to get my [ __ ] from was a 400 pound
puerto rican man named gordo
yep
yup
he had a heart of gold and a 357 a
[ __ ] nickel plate dude
that man loved his gun
and he pulled out all that oh dude and
well and not even like in a shitty way
he'd be like poppy poppy look at this
how beautiful is this he would just
[ __ ] how beautiful is this look at
this is this not
spin the [ __ ] wheel dude he loved it
and he was a nice guy dude that's the
funny thing that's the funny thing he
was such a nice man he was probably
god at that time i was
24 ish
ballpark
there's kids walking by um
[Music]
yeah he was like 24 or no i was 24 but
he was probably in his late 30s at that
point he was a super nice man and he
actually like
would do
good stuff like you know
i i'd shown up there with like you know
five dollars sick as [ __ ] dude
and he'd be like all right here and he
throw me five bags because you know i
was a loyal customer
and um
i remember that day
i went and i bought my [ __ ] dude
and i remember walking away and then
[ __ ]
jerry
walking back and forth pacing back and
forth at the end of the sidewalk
i remember him passing me
like he walked right by me [ __ ] head
down just not going for it dude
as i'm walking away i hear
hey [ __ ] and my head goes oh
[ __ ] did i not give him enough money you
know because you just [ __ ] here's a
stack of money give me my drugs and then
you beat the [ __ ] feet
dude i hear hey [ __ ] and all of
a sudden
i hear
as jerry is running at me
and i turn around
i turn around dude and i look and all of
a sudden his [ __ ] face
is
all over me
oh my god
did you just say his face is all over
you
dude
gordo shot that [ __ ] in the back
of the head and his [ __ ] face just
went
all over me dude what the [ __ ] are you
talking about right now hold on
you're telling me that you thought he
was talking to you so you turn to
see
and he shoots this guy's
skull apart and it splatters all over
you
what the [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] dude
happy too
what dude i mean you're lucky the
bullets didn't go through him and hit
you the fact that i didn't get shot that
day is insane to me what do you know
what happened why did he try to charge
gordo what the [ __ ] was he doing
he dude he went up [ __ ] was this a
suicide mission
dude he went up asked for a pack took
the pack and [ __ ] booked it and
started running up the street
so he just shot him
and he shot that [ __ ] in the
back of the head and it's breaking and
dude i
literally picked [ __ ] hair brains and
skull fragments out of my [ __ ]
everything
did you get it in your mouth
i don't even remember probably probably
i don't know dude i just turned around
and all of a sudden some dudes dude and
i remember it i remember it in slow
motion where literally like all of a
sudden you see a face and then it just
goes
oh my god
[ __ ] god you just saw it disintegrate
like that
dude disintegrate is not the word for it
disintegrate is not the word for it the
[ __ ]
dude the [ __ ] that a 45 magnum will do
to the front of somebody's face when it
comes through the back is something i
wouldn't wish dude i wouldn't wish it on
my worst enemy it dude it it covered me
from [ __ ] head to toe i was covered
in blood and snot and brains and hair
i ran
the two blocks back to my car and i sat
there for an hour and a half waiting for
the cops to come
guess who didn't come yeah nobody misses
a junkie
bro they dragged his ass into the empty
lot right next to the [ __ ] dope spot
and that [ __ ]
dude he was there for three days before
the coroner finally came straight up
dude three days
before the coroner how do you know three
days because you went right back
because
you went right back this doesn't here's
what here's the thing hold on nope this
doesn't make you want to quit heroin
this so i waited dude i waited four days
i waited four days
one day i was finally so sick dude i
couldn't take it anymore so i went back
but hold on i gotta stop you here i
gotta pause you why are you waiting in
your car for the cops to come were you
gonna be a witness like why you get the
[ __ ] i didn't know what else to do
literally
dude i was literally picking dudes i
don't care you didn't see [ __ ] do you
understand how the code works it doesn't
matter if you're [ __ ] flossing his
brains out of your teeth you didn't see
anything i'm not even sure what this is
awful i don't know i'm so scared
no no you're not wrong bro you're not
wrong i'm so scared i was like what the
[ __ ] do i do so i just sat there i was
like uh i and i was two blocks over so
it was funny doesn't it i think is it
stinking at this point like i would
imagine no there's no no no there's no
stuff
have you talked to a therapist about
this dude all you smell is all you smell
is pennies dude oh that's pure blood
iron god oh dude it was so bad man and
like dude it's still to this day like it
[ __ ] i'll wake up and i'll just be
like oh what the [ __ ] you haven't talked
to anyone about this
oh no i've talked to dude my therapist
loves me all right dude that
[ __ ] dude that [ __ ] has
so many thousands of dollars because of
me
oh man
okay so you go you you go back home you
wait four days because it did scare you
enough you're sick of [ __ ] you finally
need to get it so do you go back to
gordo
i go back to gordo now why wouldn't you
go to the other street and just go to
the [ __ ] you said he was puerto rican
right so why wouldn't you go to the
dominicans
because they're [ __ ] mean and their
[ __ ] was good they're mean he just shot
a guy's face onto your face
berto was nice though i came back dude i
came back you shot a man's face onto
your face
but dude but he was nice to me
so you go back do you do you see the
[ __ ]
do you see the any of the guys oh no
no dude no it was gun well yeah the
blood was still on the street no but the
body was gone dude
they [ __ ]
they took that [ __ ] away holy and i went
back dude and i sat down next to him on
the stoop and he looked at me he said
you okay poppy
i said
good enough he goes what do you need
and that was the last time we talked
about it
i bought a lot of heroin off that dude
he was a [ __ ]
good dude
but i mean he [ __ ]
yeah i hear you i know what you're
saying and this is what tony soprano was
a good dude you know i know yeah dude
it was [ __ ] wild
you know and dude like i did like i i
had to [ __ ] i didn't realize how
much it [ __ ] me up
until years later like
that was 2010
and i
literally just started [ __ ] dealing
with that [ __ ] um in 2015. what happened
that that made you realize oh it's this
[ __ ] coming back
um one of my good friends was killed um
he was in the military he was in iraq
and i started talking to his mom
and she started explaining to me what
had happened to him
and
i was like
oh like i
i've seen that before you know and it
started bringing up
things that i hadn't dealt with at that
point like because dude like when you
know when you're [ __ ] just piss and
junk up your arm dude like you don't
deal with it you're just like oh this is
all i care about
and then all of a sudden you start to
figure out like
yep
you gotta figure that out and then it
becomes very
very apparent that you
need to deal with a lot of stuff
and then dude like
my dad had just died in 2014 and all of
a sudden all this [ __ ] comes through and
i was just like oh my god and it it
[ __ ] me up dude it [ __ ] me up for a
couple of [ __ ] anybody up
i mean it really [ __ ] up jerry
[ __ ] jerry
jerry jerry got the worst number
dude should have kept a piece of his
nose dude
put it in my pocket dude let me ask you
i got i do want to ask you guys i know i
know you're
talking about trauma right now but
i also know from my own trauma there are
flashes and moments of absolute clarity
that are etched in your brain forever
what do you see from that did you see
eyes did you see i know you joke about
the nose did you really see no no no no
okay okay that's [ __ ] dude thank you
for asking that so
what i remember and i will tell you this
in detail
i remember turning around and hearing
bang
and then
look at your face right now i remember
seeing his face
and then from the bridge of his nose
everything just went
out
it just split open like that
dude have you ever seen what a 45 magnum
does to a [ __ ] head no
i haven't back of the head dude his face
dude literally
ryan from the [ __ ] bridge of his nose
it just went it fell laid open
i never
dude how many shots did he hit him with
one
back of the dome just one that was it
hollow point [ __ ]
my god i've been a hunter my entire life
dude i've hunted like i've killed many
an animal
like that's
that's just vermont dude that's what we
do
but the fact that [ __ ] hit him
i assume dead center back of the dome
his [ __ ] face went yup all over me
dude if he ducks or trips that bullet's
yours
and that is still to this day why i ask
myself
like
a dude all right how long did you
continue to do heroin after that
incident
uh i got cleaned in 2016. so what are we
looking at the a year after that uh
uh doug that was 2010. oh five years
after that six years after that holy
[ __ ]
okay yeah and and now i want to ask you
this so
at what point do the pills transition to
needles
oh um so that was 2011 and i remember
very vividly i was living in a [ __ ]
hotel room because you know junkie
status
um
my
friend
from rehab
hooked me up with adult boy
from
uh
where the [ __ ] was he from oh he
actually might have been from baltimore
now that i think about it
he
might be what's a dope boy is it dope
boy someone actually comes over and
shoots you up and shows you how no no no
no no adult adult boy is the guy who
come the dope boy is the guy who comes
up from the city and has the work
okay so [ __ ] walk me through your
first time putting um heroin with a
needle into your body
so the first time i was living in a
one-bedroom apartment in burlington and
my
friend from rehab
her name is ashley
um she actually has unfucked herself
she's got a little boy she's very good
um
she
was dealing with the dude out of
brooklyn
and she would go down to brooklyn every
couple of days
she would come back
but she couldn't stay at her parents
house because they were just
done with her [ __ ] so they would
[ __ ]
you know
tell her no you're not staying here so
she would stay at my little [ __ ]
basically
one bedroom hotel room apartment
and
i remember being sick as [ __ ]
and she had probably
2 000 bags
but i didn't have any money and she
wouldn't
just throw me a couple of bags to get
well she was just like well
i'll give you half a bag
and she shot me up with a half a bag
the first time where where and it was
oh dude and it was [ __ ] in your arm
running from there oh yeah yeah
yep and that was was that compared to
the pills the high from the pills are we
just like
not even a comparison like way better
way stronger
wait
dude
i don't want to glorify it because it's
[ __ ] garbage but i'll tell you what
i'd rather [ __ ] piss something up my
arm then [ __ ] take it up my nose
it's [ __ ] trash dude it's disgusting
it's so bad
have you ever overdosed
no
okay no
whatever over here
where's the craziest uh or or strangest
part of your body you shot up did you
ever have to hide your arms did you
shoot in legs did you shoot neck did you
shoot nope dude it was it was always
arms and hands i i hands okay
yeah hands oh um
i don't know if i can well you wear
those big welder's gloves so you could
hide it yeah i see there damn
goddamn dude i don't know dude like how
often were you shooting up
every day every day once a day
um as much as i could afford where are
you it could be
um
well dude you can buy them at cvs or you
can go to the needle exchange if you
have one in your town when i was in
burlington they had one and they just
give them to you or you could go to
[ __ ] cvs and you know buy a 10 pack
for three bucks
like that like there's definite and
i don't i don't like to promote it
because it's not it's not a good way of
life but like
if you're doing it dude like you can do
it and you can do it
clean like you don't have to like people
who share needles like that is just
like it just it skeeves me out your mic
again oh sorry dude careful that's robin
and stuff
it's just it's so skeevy dude like
there's so much about [ __ ] being a
dirtbag junkie you just
i'd rather not do it i'd rather just
be a drunk
so what
made you finally say
[ __ ] it i'm going clean what happened
for you
oh oh dude i didn't say [ __ ] nothing my
girlfriend and her mom locked me in a
bedroom for [ __ ] six days was it the
same girl that you wanted to piss off
she's still with you all through all
this
oh god no no dude she and i haven't been
no no
this girl and her mom literally take you
and shut you and lock you in
so we okay so i was with this girl for
three years and um
we went to her mom's house for christmas
i was that guy who [ __ ] ruined
christmas
how
i showed up strung out on heroin and
then got dope sick immediately
like in front of people uh what do you
mean dude
oh yeah you don't know sorry sorry um
yeah in front of everybody like
literally her grandma her [ __ ] woman
so
so this was the greek family
they all speak languages i don't the
only thing i know is [ __ ] melaka me
too i'll tell you right now
is what they basically call a [ __ ]
yeah and i heard a lot of malaccas in
that [ __ ]
six days dude
they locked me in a [ __ ] bedroom for
six days dude because she was done she
was like dan i love you but i'm done
with this [ __ ]
and they [ __ ] they locked me down and
i detoxed and you didn't fight try to
get out duck out the window you just
took the help bro i was in [ __ ]
massachusetts i didn't have anywhere to
go i didn't have any dude
it's
dude like i i couldn't drive like what
the [ __ ] was i going to do want to steal
her car like no it doesn't work that way
well so far you haven't made the best
goddamn decisions dan i mean jesus
christ
we don't talk about it we just know that
it's [ __ ] bad on the way let me ask
you this talk talk us through like the
detox the the withdrawals and
oh
boy okay so at first
in the beginning it um
you ever
how do i put it
do you ever just have a bad day where
like you want to cry
yeah a lot of them
[Laughter]
my guy
so it starts out like that and then all
of a sudden you get this this pain it's
not even a pain it's
it's a nervousness you get that that
anxiety right here
that's when you know it's starting to
get really bad
and then all of a sudden
two days into it
you start to feel it in your bones
in your bum like hurts
oh dude
are you throwing up the whole time
sweating shaking
uh sweating shaking yes throwing up and
pooping i never had that problem i'm
very lucky on that sense because i have
other friends who just have
dude literally [ __ ] their brains out
till they're so dehydrated i'm very
lucky there but yes dude like your bones
ache you're just [ __ ]
i i remember convulsing so hard that
like
like
dude at you know 20
not 20 like 30 32 years old like like
crying like begging just like please
make a stop please make it stop you know
like
just begging like calling my mom and my
mom you know god bless her she's just
like damn i'm not doing this with you
anymore my poor mother has [ __ ] done
this with me so
many times dude
that lady is a savage and she will never
do it again and i'm not about to [ __ ]
play that game again
ever
now what about your dad through all this
did he
so my dad died in 2014.
um my dad
was wait
you were in the middle of you were at
the height of your uh heroin abuse
okay i'm going to ask you some questions
then do you go to the funeral strung out
very
very much so and noticeable for other
people even like hey this [ __ ]
strung out at his dad's funeral
graham didn't notice it i'm sure
everybody here graham didn't but the
other girls graham did
so christmas graham noticed when you
threw up all over the goose
oh dude so fun facts dude um
my my parents were super [ __ ] awesome
um
my dad was gay
that's a long story for another podcast
but uh that is another podcast
but um my mom knew and you know [ __ ]
sick
uh he got sick yeah he did get sick um
he got cancer
in 2013
he passed in 2014 but it wasn't even the
cancer that killed him it was the
[ __ ] stroke he had because of the
weird [ __ ] drugs they had him on it
gave him a blood clot went into his leg
yeah
dude it was it was rough man it was
rough
but uh
[ __ ]
so yeah you went to the funeral [ __ ]
up
i bro
dude i stole his drugs
no
dog i stole his opiates you took your
dad's opiates while he's in the hospital
cancer yep man you were an addict
dirt bag status
garbage person
i won't [ __ ] dude i won't i hope you
totally took the opiates and not the
[ __ ] that that could have saved them
oh
no that [ __ ] dude he dude even
he was just like yo dude he had a stroke
and he he he straight up telling me he
was like yo here you go like i'm i'm
good like
they had him on so much morphine dude it
was ridiculous dude he like he threw me
a bottle of [ __ ] dilaudid and it was
just like
bro he threw me a bottle of 50 dalot and
was just like there you go [ __ ] love
you
yeah dude it was dude it was rough man i
[ __ ] i was such a [ __ ] show like
what happened to this funeral did you
get called out oh
oh bro
so
my my family's catholic and [ __ ]
the priest at their church is a dude
from africa
[ __ ] barely speaks english
lord
lord please accept david into your
kingdom
lord
[Music]
my sister and i [ __ ] laughed so
bro dude we were geeking out my
grandmother was just like why are you
laughing why are you laughing
that poor woman
my sister and i literally [ __ ] geeked
out what was your sister [ __ ] up too
or was she just laughing she was drunk
dude she was hammered dude she was one
drunk she [ __ ] dude no no no
gurts [ __ ] she no she's good people
she don't do dirt bag [ __ ] like i do
i'll tell you what though dude listen to
that guy lord
lord accept david into a kingdom of
heaven it's so bad
it's so bad
and [ __ ] we laughed so hard
so let's don't do drugs kids no
especially heroines let's jump back to
six days in the room
with the greek family you come out
and do you relapse at aldor or have you
been cleaning sober since
a sticky question
um
i think
oh that's a good question
i think i was
good
no no wrong wrong
wrong that's lies um
yeah no i relapse once
relapse is a
interesting term um i
i took suboxone because i was so sick
josh adam meyer says all these [ __ ]
you guys talk like your goddamn
pharmacist i don't even know what the
[ __ ] suboxone is either okay so boxing
is [ __ ] um an opiate
like
it's an opiate for sure but it's uh
josh adam myers get out of here with
that [ __ ] you guys talk like pharmacist
you know what it is your mic is
scratching against your beard and you're
hitting it with your hand right now oh
dude there you go
just sit still dan
my business devil woman
um so you relax well you say it's okay
so you take these things these what is
suboxosil what the hell is
so suboxone is and um
what do you call it it's not uh well it
isn't opiate but it's like um
it's what junkies take
it's like methadone
yeah it's like methadone but not
terrible gotcha jesus i hope any of this
is useful for to you guys
um
like
so methadone is you know
an opiate um
yeah i used to work next to a methadone
clinic and i'd watch everybody come in
to get their
their [ __ ]
so
you do that once and that's it in in the
last what four years
oh doug i'm still on it
what you are
yeah well does that cons but that's but
is that controlled and monitored though
oh yes no i have a doctor i have a
doctor
um i have a doctor you know um i get
tapered down
um it shouldn't be something for long
term unfortunately that's because
honestly if you went cold turkey that
could really kill you
no no you're just a [ __ ] you know
you're just a [ __ ]
no unfortunately it's not that like
alcohol and benzos are the only things
that could kill you
realistically
um
opiates
unfortunately you're just a [ __ ] and
i'm a [ __ ] i it it's it's tough dude it
sucks
drugs are bad yeah man they're bad news
well look man this
first of all thank you for coming on
here and being so open dude thank you so
much i don't know if the i don't know if
any of this is usually what are you
talking about someone's face blew up on
your [ __ ] face dude like
if that's not a say no to drugs campaign
i don't know what the [ __ ] is okay
i love it dude you i wish my favorite
person dude
here's what i wish i wish every day that
you could take a memory like that and
put that into a virtual reality camera
give that to our goggles give that to
kids for scared straight programs so
they can watch what the [ __ ] you saw
going to get heroin that day
i think this was not out of the [ __ ]
game man
it's just
i'm glad yeah i i in my you're telling
me that i'm i'm literally blown away by
everything you're saying and also i'm
thinking this is a junkie he could have
easily stubbed his foot and tripped
forward uh this much and that bullet's
going right into you
that's a crazy story dude the fact that
i didn't dude the fact that i've never
been killed in all the grimy [ __ ] i've
done
like it it blows my mind no i know
people's eyes do dead in alleys cause
they're going down the baltimore
together dude i'm serious man it's wild
like i've done some dirtbag [ __ ] but
i'll tell you what dude the fact that
i'm still alive is [ __ ] amazing to me
like
dude i was such a scumbag dude and i
love that i'm still around dude i got a
nephew i got a kitty look at this
[ __ ] idiot
oh look at you little kitty
well thank you dan for coming on the
show
thank you so much for having me man i
appreciate you a hell of a story same
brother same i appreciate you as well
and i appreciate all of you out there
who have subscribed i really i know it i
know times are tough so again if you're
in for the long haul sign up for a year
save that money update your credit cards
we'll talk to you all next
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you
[Music]